[Music]  Emily Ratajkowski is rocking a rock he  knows well fancy fancy  is an understatement for the models  massive sparkler which Jess made its  social media debut four months after she  said I do I think I really was just  eager to celebrate Emily said yes to  husband Sebastien bare my cards proposal  without a diamond he popped the question  with a paper clip instead but the wait  for the real deal seems totally worth it  Emily showed off her stunning two stone  engagement ring for the first time  featuring one teardrop cut diamond and  one princess cut diamond embedded on a  simple gold band the 27 year old star  went makeup free while flashing her  bling back in February the couple tied  the knot in a surprise wedding ceremony  at City Hall in NYC it was amazing  [Music]  [Applause]